hey guys how's it going happy tech
Tuesday I just wanted to have a quick
little chat with you guys just to go
over something that I noticed yesterday
in the Apple announcement video that has
been driving me crazy from the second
that I saw it and I didn't actually
address it in yesterday's video because
it wasn't really the key thing to recap
but after thinking about it all day and
then talking to my friend Edie did you
see that yeah I saw it but did you see
what I saw and yes we saw it when Apple
was talking about the environmental
programme that they have put in place
they announced this little robot thing
called Liam and Liam takes apart your
iPhone and when Liam was taking apart
said iPhone the iPhone that he was
taking apart doesn't exist yet because
if you look very closely the camera on
the side I found that Liam is
deconstructing the cameras not raised
what does this mean I'm not sure what it
means what it means to me is that that
phone is not out yet or someone made a
mistake be in whatever that rendering is
of Liam but I feel like Liam looked
pretty realistic and everything that was
happening in that render they probably
wouldn't have made such a big oversight
on one item that you guys are promoting
them I'm so confused I'm not sure this
is the iPhone six-plus camera raised
this is the iPhone 6s plus camera raised
we on camera not raised let's get into
this let's take a quick let's go come on
look at this what is it what is it what
are you so if you look at it that is
definitely not a raised camera the
microphone is also much closer to the
camera and the flash is also much closer
the space between these are not the same
at all let's get let's let's keep going
this that is not this that is not this
phone let's look at this side okay that
looks about the same I can't take off my
thigh phones I don't know what the
insides look like what oh I'm not even
sure what I'm looking for because I
don't know what the inside of my phone
looks like so let me know what you guys
think because this is a little bit
suspicious the entire Apple event from
yesterday definitely seemed a little
strange to me something seemed off I'm
not sure what it is were they supposed
to announce something else that they
ended up not announcing they it already
pushed this event an entire week I
thought that they were going to announce
some MacBook refreshes they didn't do
that so were they actually supposed to
announce I'm not sure am i overthinking
it I could be overthinking it there's a
really good chance that I could be
overthinking but I think there's even a
better chance that I'm not overthinking
it and I'm not crazy and does it really
matter I'm not sure I think it matters
to me well thank you guys for watching I
would love to hear what you guys think
about this small conspiracy was it a
planned conspiracy do they know that
people were gonna try to question what
phone that was or do they care do they
not care was it intentional I'm not sure
maybe I'm just a little bit crazy I'll
see you guys later
bye hey guys how's it going so I just
said I'm watching the Apple announcement
and if you guys were following my tweets
you might know how I sort of felt about
it